merci Olivier Cadic de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure membre
du groupe Union centriste vous
représenter les Français établir de
France on va bien sûr passer parler de
ce qui se passe du côté du Royaume-Uni
dans quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est cette crise et cette
sortie de crise que tente de trouver
l'exécutif Elisabeth borgne hier soir
dans un entretien à l'agence transpresse
dit vouloir l'apaisement avec les
syndicats elle va recevoir les parties
d'opposition la semaine prochaine c'est
suffisant pour vous je pense que elle
est un petit peu obligée quand même de
dire de dire ça puisque effectivement il
est nécessaire de retrouver un peu de
sérénité je crois que l'image que nous
donnons n'est pas l'image que doit
donner la France moi je vous l'avais
vous l'avez dit je suis au Royaume-Uni
donc j'ai un regard extérieur sur ce qui
se passe en France et donc les images
qui sont projetées aux quatre coins du
monde ne nous sont pas favorables et
donc il est logique la première ministre
appelle toutes les parties prenantes à
se retrouver autour de la table nous
sommes dans une démocratie et on doit
parler sereinement entre nous
la première ministre dit qu'elle n'aura
plus recours au 49.3 hors texte
budgétaire est-ce que c'est une bonne
chose pour vous bah c'est son choix de
premier ministre je pense que ce qui est
important c'est d'être efficace la
France a besoin d'avancer il y a
justement cet article 49-3 qui permet
justement de d'avoir des sorties
en disant ou au membre de l'Assemblée
nationale de prendre une position est-ce
qu'il va le rembourser renverser le
gouvernement ou pas et donc c'est un
outil si elle décide de ne pas
l'utiliser c'est son choix
utiliser le 49-3 que dans des textes
budgétaires mais c'est une position de
la première ministre encore une fois le
je pense pas que quand la Constitution a
été écrite de ce de cette façon là et là
ça avait été bien vu par le général de
Gaulle je pense d'avoir cet outil là
pour pour pouvoir avancer même quand il
y a des difficultés les nouvelles
journées de mobilisation qui est
annoncée demain la dixième à l'appel des
syndicats est-ce que vous comprenez que
les syndicats continuent la mobilisation
dans la rue alors que le texte est
désormais adopté par le Parlement
pour moi c'est un petit peu compliqué
parce que vous savez tous les ans au
Sénat depuis 5 ans maintenant nouveau
ton donc le report de l'âge légal à 65
ans il y a une évolution nous vivons
plus longtemps donc c'est c'est un débat
qui me semblait être arbitré lors de la
l'élection présidentielle il y avait une
vraie majorité pour pouvoir même à
l'Assemblée nationale il y avait une
majorité qui se dessinait pour pouvoir
faire voter le texte il y a une partie
des républicains qui ont généré en fait
cette situation qui n'aurait pas existé
si les républicains avaient été unis
pour voter un texte qui était conforme à
leur propre engagement lors de
l'élection présidentielle il se trouve
qu'on a ce sujet là aujourd'hui qui est
sur la table qui est effectivement
politique maintenant que les syndicats
ne puissent pas dire qu'est-ce qu'elle
est l'alternative parce que
l'alternative c'est quoi c'est soit on
baisse les pensions soit on augmente les
taxes sur les gens qui travaillent donc
c'est là que va se situer l'enjeu je
pense qu'on avait trouvé une solution
dont on battu d'ailleurs dans
l'hémicycle je pense que maintenant si
les syndicats veulent qu'on revienne il
va falloir qu'ils viennent eux avec de
vraies propositions pour dire comment
finance alors Laurent Berger il appelle
à mettre le texte sur pause justement
pour retravailler la solution il a
quelle est la solution comment ils
veulent financer on est dans le cas d'un
PLFSS on a un défi site c'est là où on
les attend donc mettre le texte sur
pause c'est pas la solution pour vous
mais toute façon à un moment ou un autre
il va falloir dire qui est-ce qui paye
est-ce qu'on continue à graver le
déficit à un moment ça va se payer mais
quand vous avez entre 1 million et 3,5
millions de Français dans les rues
toutes les semaines c'était le cas jeudi
dernier est-ce qu'à un moment il ne faut
pas entendre aussi le message moi je
veux bien entendre mais je vis avec un
traumatisme c'est celui de 1995 quand
Alain Juppé a dû renoncer donc à cette
réforme des retraites et à la sortie
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé le
gouvernement a été renversé derrière et
on a eu on voit bien que économiquement
budgétairement on l'a payé très cher
donc si on est obligé de revenir en
arrière c'est à dire que alors que nous
avons voté alors qu'il y a eu un vote on
est obligé de revenir en arrière va se
poser la question qu'est-ce qu'on fait
il y a un moment il va quand même
falloir repasser devant le Parlement
qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur la réforme des
retraites et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
politiquement est-ce que pour vous il y
a une alternative politique est-ce que
la dissolution pour être une solution
encore une fois c'est quand même ça
paraîtrait étrange que quelques mois
après avoir voté on doit dissoudre pour
revenir devant les électeurs donc c'est
il y a des il y a une partie de des
mouvements politiques qui n'acceptent
pas le résultat des élections nous
l'avons vu l'an dernier bien que la
France insoumise est perdue les
élections il continue à dire que le
peuple était avec eux le peuple avait
voté il ne respecte pas ce vote
populaire c'est là où est où est la
difficulté
on l'a vu dans le journal de violences
affrontements ce week-end à
Sainte-Soline dans les Deux-Sèvres lors
du manifestation interdite plusieurs
baissiers du côté des manifestants du
côté des forces de l'ordre le pronostic
vital dans des manifestants et
d'ailleurs engagé des parlementaires
étaient présents dans cette
manifestation qui était pourtant
interdite qu'en pensez-vous
je pense que les images montent par
elles-mêmes le problème et donc c'est
pas quelque chose de nouveau nous
l'avons vu aussi avec Notre Dame des
Landes on l'a vu avec d'autres
générations sur ceux qui se combattaient
les centrales nucléaires on voit ce
spectacle qui est un spectacle de
bataille rangée on n'est pas dans
l'échange d'arguments on est dans autre
chose et on le voit bien on est dans un
affrontement et on ne respecte pas les
forces de l'ordre on leur tire dessus on
voit des des camions incendiés c'est pas
c'est pas ça la démocratie et donc il
faut revenir sur
quelle est l'origine de ça comment ça se
construit on voit dans toutes les
démocraties on voit des endroits où on
cherche à déstabiliser les gouvernements
par des mouvements comme ça pour
contester l'autorité ça c'est un vrai
sujet il va falloir que peut-être on en
parle aussi au niveau du Parlement
conséquence de ce climat social tendu la
visite du roi Charles III a été reportée
elle était prévue depuis hier jusqu'à
mercredi elle a été reportée un peu la
dernière minute vendredi midi vous
revenez du Royaume-Uni ou vous résidez
vous allez nous dire dans quelques
minutes comment ça a été perçu sur place
mais d'abord on va d'abord vous devez se
rendre demain Charles III bonjour Xavier
sottard merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
journaliste à Sud-Ouest on revient
d'abord avec vous sur l'incendie
volontaire du porche de la mairie de
Bordeaux jeudi en marge de la
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites parce qu'on va voir que ça a
peut-être un rapport avec le report de
cette visite mais d'abord on en est où
de l'enquête sur cette incendie
l'enquête est en train de suivre son
cours ce qu'on sait à ce stade c'est
qu'il y a eu une série d'interpellations
et une personne un son domicile de 26
ans a été incarcéré pour les faire
d'incendie la police évidemment est en
train de mener les investigations est en
train d'exploiter toutes les preuves
dont elle dispose au cours de cette
soirée
je vous rappelle il faisait quand même
noir on s'est retrouvé face à plusieurs
dizaines d'individus masqués cagoulé
donc assez difficile de déterminer qui a
fait quoi alors évidemment il y a des
caméras de vidéos surveillance qui était
installé l'une d'entre elles étaient
coupées pour la simple et bonne raison
qui avait des coupures d'électricité
dans le cas de la contestation sociale
bref pour l'instant les investigations
se poursuivent une personne incarcérée
je vous le disais quant à l'origine et
bien écoutez c'est assez nébuleux il y a
des rumeurs qui courent en ville on est
évidemment pas là pour relayer les
rumeurs mais voilà on est en tout cas
dans allez une réminiscence des
incidents qui avait connu Bordeaux
pendant la crise des gilets jaunes ou
cette place Berlin cette place de la
mairie était venue t'es devenu le
théâtre de violon urbaine samedi après
samedi et là ça réveillait un très très
très très très mauvais souvenir très
douloureux pour Bordeaux et tout le
monde est un petit peu sous tension
puisque demain vous le disiez il y a à
nouveau une mobilisation une
mobilisation pour laquelle cette fois
la mairie de Bordeaux sera sous bonne
garde et demain vous auriez dû à
Bordeaux accueillir le roi Charles III
et est-ce que c'est cette situation
extrêmement tendue et ces images qu'on a
vu il y a quelques jours qui ont conduit
à l'annulation de cette visite
c'est très spectaculaire de voir ce
Porge de l'Hôtel de Ville enflammé des
flammes qui grimpaient à 15 20 m de haut
cette image on la retrouvée évidemment
dans les médias britanniques notamment
dans le gardien donc est-ce que ça a été
le déclencheur difficile à dire je ne
suis pas dans les secrets de Buckingham
le sénateur pourra peut-être nous
expliquer les ressorts de la diplomatie
mais quoi qu'il en soit c'est une vraie
déception pour le maire écologiste je
vais tout vous dire là il y a une petite
singularité du maire de Bordeaux il
était ravi de recevoir le roi Charles à
Bordeaux pourquoi parce qu'il y a une
longue histoire commune trois siècles de
domination anglaise sur l'Aquitaine
Aliénor d'Aquitaine ça finit à la guerre
de Cent Ans la bataille de Castillon
parce que l'anglais les Anglais ont
laissé une trace très fort très
puissante la fortune des vins de
Bordeaux et bien on la doit pour partir
aux Anglais à l'époque pendant cette
époque on est vraiment dans le bas
Moyen-Âge voilà le monopole des
commerces des vins était accordé au à
Bordeaux et puis ensuite évidemment du
chêne a est revenu dans le giron
français mais il y avait toujours eu ce
lien très étroit très particulier
jusqu'au 18e et on doit aux Anglais
d'avoir structuré notre vignoble on a
une spécificité dans le vignoble
bordelais c'est le négoce et bien le
négoce on le doit aux enquêtes grandes
familles aujourd'hui le président du
CFDB l'interprofession la plus grosse de
France est dirigée par un certain Alan
seichel qui est d'origine britannique
évidemment
Xavier vous avez une question oui
absolument mais ça boucle un petit peu
tous les sujets du jour entre ces
spectacles de violence au terme des
manifestations des retraites
sainte-solines on l'a vu pour monsieur
le député pour monsieur le sénateur
évidemment la question c'est de savoir
est-ce que l'image de la France
aujourd'hui est durablement dégradée au
Royaume-Uni
je crois que c'est un spectacle
malheureusement qu'on a souvent donné et
donc il y a une sorte de romantisme de
la part des Britanniques quand ils
regardent la France et ils sont je
dirais je l'écoutais j'entendais à la
radio à la BBC encore ce week-end
effectivement cette façon de commenter
cette cette action ces actions en France
qui ne sont pas du tout
perçus de la même façon les Britanniques
ne pas n'ont pas cette approche là il y
a d'abord il y a une notion de respect
qui est je dirais dans le cadre de
l'éducation britannique est encore
fortement après donc enseigner et qui
qui fait que on ne va pas commettre des
prédations sinon on va aller en prison
ou sinon ça va vous coûter très très
cher sous forme sous forme d'amande donc
il y a quand même il y a quand même un
cadre qui est différent ceci étant c'est
effectivement vous vous parlez de
Bordeaux il y a un consulat britannique
à Bordeaux c'est très bien expliqué donc
sur le sur ce côté
proximité et d'ailleurs le vin de
Bordeaux beaucoup l'appel toujours le
Clairet et donc ils ont gardé le nom
original du vin de Bordeaux c'est il y
avait quelque chose qui qui relevait
comment dire dans le voyage du roi
Charles III
qui relevait en fait d'une symbolique
très forte dans le prolongement dans la
suite de ce qu'avait fait sa mère qui
avait eu ce premier déplacement il y
avait une forte un fort attachement
symbolique à la proximité à conserver
cette proximité entre la France et le
Royaume-Uni ça n'est que partie remise
et c'est ce qui a été dit puisque ça
n'est que reporté mais ceci étant
évidemment au niveau de l'image à un
moment important puisque je voudrais
quand même rappeler à certains que il y
a la guerre en Ukraine que eux en
Ukraine ils ont ils reçoivent des
missiles sur la tête qui leur vient
directement du camp de Monsieur Poutine
à ce moment là on avait besoin
effectivement de tourner totalement la
page du brexit et c'était quelque chose
de très fort qui devait se passer
retrouver ce côté entente pour aller de
l'avant on va parler des relations
franco-britanniques mais c'était ce
report enfin l'annonce de ce report un
peu la dernière minute 48 heures avant
l'arrivée de Charles III est-ce que ça
vous a surpris est-ce que ça a surpris
les Britanniques
évidemment c'était
pensait que le Président de la
République pourrait quand même
concrétiser cette cet événement je pense
que s'il a pris cette décision c'est
qu'il avait des informations qui lui
permettait de penser que ça ne se
passerait pas bien et que on le voit on
le voit il y a une volonté de remettre
en cause l'autorité de déstabiliser
notre pays certains cherchent à nous
mettre dans une mauvaise position pense
que peut-être que comme ça ils auront
des élections ils auront à nouveau leur
chance de prendre le pouvoir je pense
que c'est dommageable pour nous ceci
étant je le comprends et je pense encore
une fois que le Président de la
République s'il l'a fait c'était pas de
gaieté de cœur et s'il a fait vendredi
matin c'est qu'il avait qui lui laissait
à penser que ça ne se passerait pas bien
comment on commence a été perçu au
Royaume-Uni vous qui en revenez est-ce
que les Britanniques en ont parlé ce
week-end comment ils ont vécu ça donc
c'est un c'est un report j'irai c'était
c'était une visite très honnêtement n'en
a pas parlé plus que ça lors du gala
vendredi soir du Collège Français
bilingue de Londres ou la Communauté
française était la réunie c'est un ces
reportés aujourd'hui on est plus dans le
phénomène de finir en fait de refermer
totalement cette page brexit de pouvoir
repartir de l'avant reconstruire on a
des problèmes au niveau international
qui sont qui touchent donc notre futur
notre avenir on est côte à côte face à
des pays qui nous menacent qui menacent
les démocraties et c'est comme ça à mon
avis qu'il faut regarder l'actualité
faut prendre du recul et se dire qu'on
va aller de l'avant et donc Charles III
viendra cet été ça a été Ann et donc
reste à définir la date et on fera
certainement un grand événement et je
donne rendez-vous à tout le monde pour
soutenir et pour pour aller de l'avant
pour construire une relation
franco-britannique positive et
constructive et pour reprendre la
question de Xavier est-ce que ça abîmait
l'image de la France au Royaume-Uni je
pense que le encore une fois on les
Britanniques connaissent aiment la
France quoi qu'en disent certains
beaucoup beaucoup ont fait le choix de
d'y acheter une maison on le voit
certains ont fait le choix de prendre
notre nationalité aussi pour pour
pouvoir y vivre tranquillement
c'est encore une fois notre notre image
c'est pas que le Royaume-Uni c'est c'est
le niveau international pensez-y depuis
quelques années le président de la
République avait vraiment changé l'image
au niveau international il donnait envie
aux investisseurs étrangers d'investir
plutôt en France plutôt qu'en Allemagne
ou dans d'autres pays on est devenus la
première destination c'est pas perdu ce
qui est important c'est qu'on puisse
créer des emplois qu'on puisse
développer notre économie et que on
puisse créer de la richesse qu'on puisse
partager parce que à la fin au bout du
bout la retraite c'est ça on va
continuer à parler des relations
franco-britanniques mais on va remercier
Xavier merci beaucoup Xavier sauta
d'avoir été avec nous regarde la Une de
Sud-Ouest mega bassine faut-il un
moratoire c'est à la Une de votre
journal et puis Xavier on signale la
sortie de votre livre sorti vendredi
livre écrit avec Jefferson des sports
sur pierre urmik le maire de Bordeaux un
écolo à l'épreuve du pouvoir c'est le
titre de votre livre merci beaucoup
Xavier d'avoir été avec nous alors on
continue à parler de ces relations
franco-britanniques un Europort de la
visite de Charles III met-elle à mal les
relations entre la France et le
Royaume-Uni et où on sont d'ailleurs ces
relations à l'heure actuelle on fait le
point avec Alex tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Olivier caddy et
Alex l'animation de cette visite royale
intervient à un moment où les relations
franco-britanniques c'était réchauffé
ces dernières semaines on le rappelle
depuis quelques années les relations
franco-britanniques se sont un petit peu
dégradées après le brexit on se souvient
d'un Boris Johnson quand il était au
pouvoir assez agressif en version voisin
français l'éphémère Premier ministre
première ministre listrus c'était même
demandé publiquement si Emmanuel Macron
était un ennemi ou un ami de son pays et
puis Richie sounaque est arrivé au 10
dolling Street à l'automne dernier et
cela a produit l'effet d'un rayon de
soleil entre les deux rives de la Manche
richessuna qui Emmanuel Macron même
organisé il y a quelques semaines un
sommet franco-britannique pour repartir
sur de bonnes bases écouter le Premier
ministre britannique
si nous sommes honnêtes les relations
entre nos deux pays ont connu des
difficultés ces dernières années et je
ne parle pas seulement du fait que la
France a éliminé l'Angleterre de la
Coupe du monde mais je crois que tu vas
réunion d'aujourd'hui marque un nouveau
départ et une entente renouvelée nous
nous tournons vers l'avenir un avenir
qui s'appuie sur tout ce que nous
partageons notre histoire notre
géographie et nos valeurs et un avenir
beaucoup plus ambitieux quant à gabanir
dont nous travaillons ensemble pour
améliorer les conditions de vie des
personnes que nous servons
voilà une nouvelle relation
franco-britannique qui est également
souhaitée par Emmanuel Macron on va
l'écouter lors de ce sommet
dans ce contexte qui place l'Europe au
sens géographique du terme face à des
responsabilités nouvelles nous deux
membres permanents du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies membres
fondateurs de l'OTAN puissance dotée
avec des intérêts communs et des vrais
convergences nous voulons travailler
ensemble et nous voulons bâtir des
solutions concrètes pour notre avenir et
donc la France et le Royaume-Uni sont
donc d'accord pour renforcer leur
coopération d'abord dans la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine qui est un
véritable défi notamment pour les côtes
du Pas-de-Calais partenariat élargi
aussi en matière de défense et une
meilleure coordination dans l'aide
militaire envoyée à l'Ukraine notez que
les relations s'améliorent également
entre le Royaume-Uni et l'Union
européenne dans la négociation de
l'après brexit le problème de l'Irlande
du Nord et de l'Irlande du Nord étant
passe d'être résolu on le rappelle après
le brexit et bien les contrôles ont été
rétablis entre le Royaume-Uni et l'Union
européenne mais il était hors de
question de d'instaurer une frontière
sur le territoire irlandais entre la
République d'Irlande membre de l'Union
européenne et à l'Irlande du Nord
membres du Royaume-Uni un pas de retour
d'une frontière en Irlande pour des
raisons historiques les contrôles
avaient donc été et bien déplacé entre
l'Irlande du Nord et le reste du
Royaume-Uni ce qui n'était pas non plus
convenable pour les partisans de l'unité
du Royaume-Uni et il y a quelques
semaines et bien européen et britannique
se sont mis d'accord dans le cadre d'un
accord appelé accord de Windsor sur une
frontière mouvante ou les produits
venant du Royaume-Uni en Irlande du Nord
pourront circuler librement seuls ceux
qui sont à destination de la République
d'Irlande connaîtront des contrôles donc
voilà l'après brexit est en train de se
négocier Olivier Cadic est-ce que
l'annulation de cette visite peut mettre
un mâle assez relations
franco-botaniques qui étaient en train
de se réchauffer ce n'est pas une
annulation de visite c'est un report
donc donc non je ne pense pas je pense
que les intérêts qui ont été défendus
tant par le Premier ministre britannique
par le Président de la République lors
de ce sommet ont été de vraiment de
montrer quels sont les points de
convergence qui nous amènent à devoir
travailler aujourd'hui ensemble pour
construire je dirais un avenir commun le
Premier ministre britannique la rappeler
nous avons des valeurs communes et nous
avons en face de nous des régimes qui
veulent détruire les démocraties qui
l'ont annoncé qui veulent mettre à basse
cette organisation
nous-mêmes voulons défendre ces
démocraties même si c'est pas si facile
que ça de et on le voit en ce moment de
diriger une démocratie ça veut dire que
chacun puisse s'exprimer à sa façon
normalement de dans le respect mais
aujourd'hui les Britanniques ont bien
dit que ils voulaient avancer on a
effectivement pu régler le problème qui
était vraiment le problème brexit
c'était de savoir comment ça allait se
passer pour l'Irlande du Nord donc il y
a un accord qui ou encore une fois on a
trouvé un moyen vu l'expérience de oui
il y a certains produits qui sont
destinés à l'Irlande du Nord uniquement
il y a pas de risque qui viennent qui
rentrent dans l'Union européenne donc on
s'est mis d'accord
on verra l'application notre difficulté
c'est plutôt que certains unionistes
encore en Irlande du Nord quelque part
sont encore en train de faire
l'assurance cher mais ce qui est
important c'est que en face de nous il y
a des pays qui nous veulent qui ne nous
veulent pas que du bien on voit qu'il y
a des conflits en Ukraine
potentiellement on voit qu'il va y avoir
des conflits dans la dopacifique on voit
que nos intérêts sont communs il faut
s'allier il faut se préparer et c'est ça
un petit peu qui était annoncé depuis
l'éclatement de la guerre en Ukraine on
parle beaucoup de la construction d'une
défense européenne est-ce que l'avenir
de cette défense européenne peut reposer
aussi sur le Royaume-Uni qui n'est plus
membre de l'UE et qui est quand même
très lié aux États-Unis
le aujourd'hui les enjeux
auxquels nous sommes confrontés et c'est
pour ça qu'il va y avoir une loi de
programmation militaire qui doit prendre
en compte des enjeux importants nous
voyons bien que d'autres pays s'arment
très fort le budget de la Chine augmente
on voit bien que des pays comme le Japon
se sont obligés de doubler leur budget
militaire nous-mêmes en Europe il n'y a
que les Britanniques qui ont une
capacité nucléaire de l'arme nucléaire
il y a la France donc nous sommes amenés
à réfléchir ensemble au niveau de la
défense mais il y a un autre succès
politique a réussi le président de la
République au niveau européen c'est
cette communauté politique européenne il
va y avoir le deuxième sommet qui va
avoir lieu à kishino donc en Moldavie le
premier juin il va y avoir donc ça c'est
pas uniquement l'Union européenne c'est
justement le Royaume-Uni est autour de
la table les pays des Balkans ce sont
tous les Européens qui sont réunis pour
réfléchir justement comment avancer
ensemble c'est un c'est un succès
politique dont on ne parle pas c'est lié
ces suites à la présidence française de
l'Union européenne on avance on avance
tous ensemble on se réunit on réfléchit
ensemble et on prend les décisions
ensemble effectivement vous avez raison
de le dire la défense ce qui se passe en
Ukraine est un sujet qui accélère ce
rassemblement
dernière question sur la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine on a connu ces
dernières années à des tensions entre la
France et le Royaume-Uni justement sur
cette gestion de cette frontière
notamment des côtes du Pas-de-Calais
est-ce que on va progresser vous êtes
sentiment qu'on va progresser sur ce
point dans les prochaines années et je
pense qu'il faut pas que les gens chacun
reste sur son quant à soi parce que côté
britannique il y a des gens qui se
plaignent effectivement de voir les
migrants arrivés pour ces personnes bien
souvent c'est une c'est la dernière
étape d'un parcours semé d'embout bûches
dans lequel il risque leur vie et
certains perdent la vie dans la Manche
c'est pas une situation humainement
acceptable d'un autre côté les gens qui
les riverains sur les côtes de la Manche
vivent aussi une situation
inacceptable avec donc avec ces gens qui
arrivent comme dans une impasse à cet
endroit là c'est une problématique j'ai
envie de dire humanitaire que l'on doit
régler par le haut il faut que chacun a
réfléchissent ensemble trouve des
solutions ensemble et pas qu'on s'envoie
les migrants les uns aux autres à la
face c'est les gens qui sont dans cette
situation sont dans une situation
catastrophique et faut penser à eux
aussi humainement il faut que là aussi
ensemble on réfléchissant on trouve des
solutions merci Alex à tout à l'heure on
parlera d'Elizabeth borne exactement
merci beaucoup Olivier Cadic merci
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans
le club d'étatoires on parlera
d'Elizabeth borde et on reviendra
également sur les violences ce week-end
à sainte-solin lors d'une manifestation
interdite contre les mégas bassiniens on
va en parler tout de suite avec notre
prochaine invité c'est Sandrine Rousseau
qui nous rejoint